hi everyone been getting some questions
from some business owners in these
strange Corona times what to do if the
business is really struggling a lot of
small businesses are probably gonna go
under in these very very strange times
if the company is really really
struggling the the best thing I could
remain commend to sit down with your
employees and figure it out one of my
favorite stories of a company that went
through hard times is Barry Wayne Miller
and Bob Chapman instead of laying people
off what he did was is he had a
mandatory furlough program where every
employee had to take four weeks of
unpaid vacation they didn't have to take
it consecutively they could take it
whenever they wanted everybody from the
most senior to the most junior had to
take it and the philosophy was better we
should all suffer a little than any of
us should have to suffer a lot this is
these are not normal times this is not
just like normal performance issues I
highly recommend that if your company is
really really struggling sit down with
the people and see if you can all figure
out a solution together share the books
with everybody show them the numbers of
how much money is going up and coming in
and engage them and see if they can help
find a solution again better we should
all suffer a little than anyone should
have to suffer a lot which is kind of
what we're all doing together in these
times anyway which is we're all shaking
our hands and keeping social distance
which is hard for social animals we're
all suffering a little with the hope
that very few people have to suffer a
lot I hope that helps as more questions
come in and as I have more thoughts I'll
share them soon be help everyone take
care of yourself and take a care of each
other
[Music]